ECHNOLOGY ISIBLE
IT'S BROUGHT US LIFE
OTO
ITAN BE CREEPY AND DARK AS
DONEY O'SULLIVAN.
TURNED AIN BEE
NATIONAL
CUY DEEP FAKES.
OWN UDING MY OWN.
M HI, HONEY.
VOICE SOUND DIFFERENT
TO Y.  S. AMERICALLY ME.
THIS IE MADE B
CO
E
OM
SORRY.
THERE'S BEEN APLOSION IN
FAKE AUDIO ANDOIG
GENERATED THROUGTIFICIAL
LLOLY. AN AI CLONE LEONARDO DiP
THEY HAVE SAIDT
ANYTHING.
EVEN --
>>NDERSON 'VE COME HERE TORKELE
INTHEOA LOT OF.
IT' REALLY ARNCE YOU PUT ASIDE
NVINCING FGOOD.SOUNDS PRETTY GOL
INCLUDING THIS.  A BEP THAT'S A
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>>S D.ONNT.
>>D ST H WE DECIDO PUT ITTITEY
M ABOURY
MOBAD SEE K HER WITH TVOICE.
>> YH.
>> I'M NARE. HLOUM.
>> HI,
>> APHONE, SAY A QUIO D?>>
DONIE.
HI,OW ARE,
>> HOW YOU?
>> WHAT ARE
JT FINISHED SHOOTING OUHE
I' AIRPORT IN >> OE GOING THIW
CONVERSATIONITH THAIDONID O ME
BETTER LATER
Y PARENTOMT ULTIMATELY THELL FOR
>> YOUVOIC
LITTONWER ANT
MYSTERI
>> ALL RIGHTDONIE -- L CALLOU L
BYES  CLASSIC?
WRONG WITH MY SO
THE S , EVERYTHING'S NE.  CLOSES
CEREMOITH A QUESTIONE GIVEN A C
WOULD YOU
UNLIMITEN BUT NO
VIME
TRUINGS GOING VIRAL ONLIND TH
E WEAR
ERLD
WHERE Y  ANY AUDIO, ANE, ANYCE C
REALN  REALITY. NIES DEVELOPIN O
EFFECTS. IALEG
TREE AND
INRLD.
THERE'S ONE WORLD.
WHEN TNGY HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR COMMUNITIES,
T D HAVE
FUCOME TO GRIP
RESPONSIBILITIES HERE.
IN THI'CONTINUE COLLEUEERE'S IA
SAID SAY THIS.
>> DONIEN IS
THE , YOISO ME AMAZING.D NEVER .
ITUN.S SONT IN THAT PIECE,
CALL THEIR AND, YOU
KNOW, HAVE SAM
SAYING YOU WERE IN TROUBLE
NEDIEAH.
MY PARENTS ARBELIEVE.
>> THEY ARE WE. DONIE?OK, WE HA
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLE. EEP FAKE
OULD STARTING
20LE THINK ABOUT THEMOUTH.
IO HASROMNEY TAPE.THE PEEV K TH
REPORT WHERE THEY WERE ABLE TO
BRCO>> I CANE THCTIVE WHO HAED .